我最懂聯盟
叫我阿嬤別熬夜的醫生
都比他早過世了
一群S胖子
一個飯後甜點
他人生快樂被你說成活成這樣
醫師實在太缺德
我常常會想說
為什麼大家反應那麼激烈
很多時候其實
OK
這太有趣了
從醫學院畢業到現在40多年
幹過很多事
但是從來沒有想過
有一天需要
能夠
會在這裡
對100萬個人說話
從第一支很陽春的影片
到今天的100萬訂閱
謝謝你們
一路陪著初日頻道
走到這裡
為了紀念這個特別的時刻
我們企劃呢
特別把大家平常想問
但可能不太好意思問的問題
都搜集了起來
我就來老實的回答了
第一
機器很爛
第二
場地很爛
因為經常我們要
就在辦公室的那個吧檯上面
我們就給他拍起片來了
然後常常拍到一半
我們的小編就說
對不起 宋醫師
我們剛剛那個電路沒有通
對不起宋醫師
麥克風不WORK
那個磁片（記憶卡）滿了
記得剛開始的幾個錄影就是
一個片子要錄很久很久
才會完工
為了找地方
我們換過辦公室
常常必須叫同事不要吵
然後換到小樹屋
錄到一半喔咿喔咿
外面的（救護車）哇哇叫
最後想我們就說
哎呀
我們有個同事住在木柵的某個山莊
想說山莊白天應該沒有什麼人
我們就到她那邊去
更好笑的是錄到一半
她媽媽回來了
我的粉絲
我們全完蛋
總之那段時間
我的心情就是覺得
好事多磨呀
要錄成一個片子
簡直是太困難了
應該是我跟蔡英傑老師拍的那個
等於是我們初日會客室的
第一個講到益生菌的片子
因為我覺得兩個老男人
突然在那樣的背景之下
看起來
兩個人都還挺帥的
所以覺得那個片子還滿值得回味的
其他跟
別的年輕人一起拍的
我都不太敢看是因為
憑良心講我是一個很害羞的人
我連自己的照片都不好意思回看
常常有人跟我講說
這支片子點閱率滿高的
那我就會回去看一下
那至於我除了醫學頻道之外
我常看的是
各位一定不會相信
我對歷史故事很有興趣
所以只要是講故事的頻道
常常都是我常常愛看的
那些考古的故事
牽涉到人類的起源的那些故事
我非常愛看
那另外我個最愛看的
最近
就是AI
只要跟AI有關的題目
大概都會
抓住我的視野來看一下
這三類是我最愛看的東西
我以前認為飲食是一切
萬病始於腸胃
這個感覺好像就是希波克拉底
就是我們西醫的始祖
一開始講的
你的良藥就是你的飲食
你的飲食就是你的良藥
可是我最近這幾年的
比較深的體會是說
尤其我到了某個年紀之後發現
運動實在是太重要的
我其實從很年輕的時候
就開始去跑步
後來仔細回想
這些年來我覺得
我的身體的狀態
一直還不錯
以前我都是慢跑
最近幾年都是騎車
然後最近加上
家裡有了這個重訓室之後
我發現運動真的是
最重要的改善健康的一件事情
你只要
開始運動
你的健康情況一定會改變
好 我就是一個普通人
我從很年輕的時候就知道
自己是普通人
普通人就有普通人的
一切的習慣
所以你們想問到的壞習慣
我全有
馬桶上看手機是
當然是有手機之後就看手機
沒手機之前
我通常會在馬桶上
把一本武俠小說看完才出來
所以我上廁所的時間很長
但是真正
有東西掉下來時間不多
不知道我這是一般人的共同感覺吧
廁所上看書特別有效率
記得特別牢對不對
我承認以前我絕對是屬於亂吃一組
而且是屬於停不下來的好吃一組
我的食量很大
在我第一本書我曾經講過
我小時候
一餐可以吃12碗飯
我小時候到我姑姑家
我們當時有七個孩子
他每個孩子算十五個餃子
我一個人吃了五十二個
所以我以前會失守
但是自從我理解
食物對健康的重要之後
看到這個211餐盤
當時叫做哈佛健康餐盤
反正我從那個時候開始就
養成了對食物的警戒心
所以你現在問我會不會失守
我還真的不會失守
就是壞的食物
打從心底我就不會去想吃它
我想吃它的時候是
我決定今天我想要試試看
我看很多書
然後也很多書讓我印象深刻
但是有一本書是
讀了之後到現在
成為我一生奉為圭臬的
一本書的觀念
那本書叫做
萬曆十五年
我剛才去看了一下新版
它後面真的加註了
一個無關緊要的年份（口誤）
為什麼要去看呢
我看那本書之後
才發現裡面它深邃的意義
事實上是講說
神宗萬曆皇帝做了一個
看起來似乎毫無意義的事情
就是他決定不上朝了
不上朝的意思就是說
他不想聽大臣胡說八道了
可是就這個不上朝那一件事情
就等於影響了
他往後100年
明朝的國運
就從那一年開始
明朝開始敗亡
就作者黃仁宇的角度來看
其實是有意義的
回歸到人生
就是你人生當中的任何一天
的任何一件事情
對於你整個人生來講
或說對於整個歷史來講
都有他的積極意義
重點是每一天該做什麼呢
每一天
就做你那天該做的事就好了
也都很重要
因為它就會影響你後面的日子
所以我從那時候開始
就對於事情
不那麼執著
但也不那麼輕忽
我覺得影響我的人生態度
還蠻大的
雖然我看起來表面平靜
其實我內心澎湃
我是一個很容易被感動的人
所以我說
我自己去騎車
我為什麼對於那些年輕人
踩著上坡的時候
我看著他們踩
我很感動
然後下溜的時候
看著一個中年的車友
一個女生
瘦巴巴的可以這樣衝50公里
我也很有感
我基本上看到
世間的活著這件事情就很有感了
自從
我知道說感謝這件事情
叫做什麼意思的時候
我其實
真的是對周遭的每一個人
我都抱著感謝的態度
我覺得每一個人
當他很認真生活的時候
我是認為說
認真的人
最美
很多人都知道我會
拉琴、玩音樂
我喜歡照相
唯一我很少談
其實對地緣政治很有興趣
真正對地緣政治發生
深厚的興趣
還是從俄烏戰爭開始
因為當時大家就講說
今日烏克蘭明日台灣
我當時就很害怕
歐洲我去過很多次
過去對歐洲這是充滿了迷惘
然後對於美國也是充滿了崇拜
然後開始對於他們重新認識
還有日本
就開始去了解
從我前一陣子對於
醫療代謝的熱衷
突然一下子轉念就開始對於
地緣政治的熱衷
所以你問我有什麼
不為人知的興趣
我現在對於每一個國家
怎麼去看其他國家
各國人到底怎麼看自己
還滿有興趣的
至於說歌單我沒有特別定歌單
我就是在
Apple Music裡面的古典
你如果印象最深刻的就是
巴哈的無伴奏
是經常會被播放的
然後有幾個曲子
因為我都是在開車的時候聽
所以我其實記不得它曲名
後來我發現戴耳機有點危險
所以我就後來就帶了一個
隨身的那個藍牙（音響）
常常就塞在我的那個椅墊下面
所以有人家會看不到我的聲音出自哪裡
可是一靠近我就說
怎麼好高雅在你旁邊的騎車
我說：嗯
大提琴就會讓你騎起來很優雅
過去一年前三名
大概都是 AI、AI、AI
就是 ChatGPT、Perplexity
跟現在 Gemini
是我前三名最常用的
第二組就是 Google 查 paper
所以 PupMed 是我最常看的網站
第三個 App 就是我最常看的
就是 YouTube 裡面的
知識性的網站
我有時候還滿無聊的
那種三小時的訪談
我有時候也會看
（宋醫師害羞）
小時候我真的最想當的是音樂家
但是後來我知道我有個大問題
就是我的拍子很不準
所以我知道我一定不會成為
一個專業的音樂家
因此我特別喜歡巴哈無伴奏
因為可以不用管別人的節奏
宋醫師 我記得你女兒也會樂器
我女兒是吹長笛
小女兒跟我一樣沒耐心
她去學小提琴的時候
我當時就跟她講說小提琴很難
她說你可以拉大提琴
我為什麼不可以拉小提琴
我跟你不一樣
我女兒就非要去挑戰它
那時候剛好是疫情期間
透過Zoom的上課
老師叫她拉這個
她就一直在打那個電腦
那電腦是我的
我就說你要摔
你可以摔壞你的琴摔掉
後來我當時就把那個話筒接過來
跟那個老師講說
老師
其實你已經跟她講過很多次
她不一定要學小提琴對不對
她說對
宋爸爸 妳的女兒
其實可以選別的
當時我剛好太太也在旁邊
所以我們就說我們可以下決定了吧
不要再讓女兒受這個苦了
所以我當場就把她的小提琴封起來
從此以後我小女兒就很快樂
因為她不必因為姐姐
長笛吹得不錯
就必須去學 學琴
小女兒就很快樂
古話叫做
「莫慌張，莫遲疑。」
我小時候聽到這句話的時候
不知道它在講什麼
後來呢 我去學股票
古票裡面大家就會講一句話
叫做「不要急，不要停。」
我現在回過頭來講說
原來這兩句話是兜在一塊兒的
我現在回頭看我年輕的時候
最犯錯的時候就是我急了
第二事情就是我拖了
所以莫慌張
就是任何事情你都不要急躁
莫遲疑就是
任何事情你該做的時候
千萬不要拖
英文叫Procrastination
我剛學會這個英文字的時候
覺得它很難
可是後來我在聽到很多英文的
提升生活的這種
或是增高你個人表達
表現的這種演講裡面
幾乎都會提到
如何去避免Procrastination
我才發現原來
「遲疑、拖」是大部分人的毛病
所以我現在如果要給年輕的自己
跟各位聽眾朋友
觀眾朋友
如果有一句建議的話
就是任何事情都不要急躁
但是都不要停下來
「莫慌張，莫遲疑。」
「不要急，不要停。」
如果你能掌握這兩個原則
第一個你不會把事情弄壞
第二個你不會拖累事情
慢慢做一步一腳印
聽起來很無聊
但是真的是有效的
好吧我就在這邊先做一個表達
但是到時候如果沒有到
不准笑
不准嘲笑我
我一直想在70歲之後
變成一個肌肉男
然後開始當一個肌肉男的模特兒
70歲的老肌肉男模特兒
這是我的下一個目標
不准笑
有發現嗎
每支影片都有準備小禮物
之前沒領到沒關係
現在幫你一次補齊
我們精選九款
最受歡迎的健康小測驗
搭配醫師營養師的實用內容
整理成九宮格健康大禮包
點擊右上方按鈕
就能免費領取囉
在這條路上
我不是一個人
初日會走到今天
是因為有很多一起打拚
一起成長的夥伴
有些問題
也來聽聽他們的想法
（回憶當初～）
就是短頭髮
然後跟宋醫師在小房間裡面
第一集我記得是跟宋醫師
拍那個減重理論
第一支影片應該是跟宋醫師
合拍的那一支
那一次拍攝的經驗其實還蠻煎熬的
對我來說
我算是一個拍影片的小白
印象中應該是蠻矬的
（笑）
但是我有很努力的保持鎮定
我那時候很緊張
那時候應該壓力蠻大
因為第一次要在鏡頭前面
跟大家講這麼
比較複雜的學問
後來那天我記得拍攝
明明其實不長的影片
我們好像也是花了三、四個小時
所以那時候準備很多東西
可是實際上真的講出來的話
大概就準備的不到五分之一
（笑）
因為太緊張了
能夠講得其實蠻少的
我覺得是不斷的成長跟進化
因為像我們一開始頻道
我剛剛加入的時候
我記得那時候才十幾萬
你看現在已經來到百萬
所以我覺得是我們
不斷在累積經驗
跟累積我們想要分享的東西
重點不是我有沒有把那些東西背熟
是我有沒有傳達到
我想傳達的東西給觀眾
或是觀眾有沒有獲得
後來我覺得把這個當成
是比較重要的事情以後
就可以比較沒那麼緊張了
除此之外就是
好像也沒有像以前會覺得
滿質疑自己到底可不可以
勝任好這份工作的
不過隨著其實大家在
這個頻道的回饋
我慢慢知道
其實我也是可以分享一些
有意義的東西給大家
所以很開心跟大家一起
前進成長這樣子
那我抽到的是3號
厭世嫉俗之家
以下是幾個範例
放心啦
這是有錢人才能煩惱的
我們M型社會邊邊的
就算睡飽還是在等死
一個飯後甜點
他人生快樂被你說成活成這樣
醫師實在太缺德
21歲那麼年輕
這種程度很容易啦
請舉老人成功的例子
活著就要吃
就是要呼吸啊
得病本來就很正常
那別吃了
反正也沒用
還有我覺得這些建議
都是有錢人才能做的
這類留言其實並不算少啦
那其實一開始啊
看到這樣留言
我常常會想說
為什麼大家反應那麼激烈
那不過後來啊
我自己想一想
很多時候其實
那是一種被否定的感覺
就是當有醫師跟你說
你這樣生活不行的時候
我那個防衛機制就起來了
但我很想跟酸民說
不要那麼緊張
放輕鬆
我們沒有人要批評你們
其實我們只是
指引說這個方式
可能會讓你過得更好
那如果當你對於
現在生活的很滿意的話
其實那就不用焦慮
就當作一個新知來去瞭解
好我抽到的是
人身攻擊小隊
舉例他就會說
找一個手臂壯
但肚子有夠大的人來講
實在是
嘉賓胖嘟嘟的
講解的再咬牙切齒
好像也沒太大說服力
看他的一雙麒麟臂
怎麼能教人減肥
這個教授先減肥吧
一群S胖子
耍嘴皮的垃圾
OK
留這種言的酸民們
我想要跟你說
其實啊
一個人說的話
就是他內心的投射
懂得就懂
我最懂聯盟
這是什麼東西
留言內容有包括
這兩個人都是AI人吧
這支影片是AI吧
這些根本不用醫生
直接抽血上網查就好了
醫生不是營養師
也不會告訴你
平衡脂肪酸的油是最好的
作息固定不行嗎
為什麼一定要十一點前睡
叫我阿嬤別熬夜的醫生
都比他早過世了
好可怕
還是搬去住沙哈拉沙漠好了
活著就要得病是很正常的
不要自己嚇自己
神棍油
好 可能在講我們精油那一集
下一個滿有趣的
他說
我覺得我們都要生活在
無菌空間裡面
這太有趣了
那還是感謝我們這些觀眾朋友的留言
你還真的花了時間看完
才知道他到底是不是AI
其實兩個人都不是AI
其實現在訊息上真的太大
你也是要好好分辨一下是不是AI
居然有AI影片可以觀看數比我們還高
我覺得這個還蠻誇張的
然後第二個是活著就得病
這絕對是不正常
就是我接下來要跟各位講的抗老化
人
一定會變得比較老
但是不一定會生病
譬如說你病到老化
那就是一種疾病
那是不應該發生的
所以要好好的訓練自己
所以這些留言
我覺得非常非常有趣
也感謝你們有好好把影片看完
才會有這樣的想法
非常棒
請持續的關注我們
我會給你更多
好的一些知識的內容
讓你們得到更多健康上的幫助
謝謝
謝謝你們讓我覺得
我做的事情是有意義的
這倒不是什麼敷衍的這種詞語
其實我是真的很誠心的感謝
因為實際上每個頻道之所以要成長
其實一定是有大家的支持在的
只有大家會願意觀看
會願意回饋的時候
我們才有那個動力
想要去把影片做得更好
所以我想不管是
新觀眾或老觀眾
其實都可以去看我們的以前的影片
跟現在的影片
質感其實是不一樣的
當然內容我們也持續的精進
所以我邀請大家再給我們更多支持
我相信我們在下一個100萬
可以提供更好的品質給大家
趕快訂閱 長命百歲
謝謝每位初日醫師的參與
讓頻道發光發熱
除了醫師，還有很多你們熟悉的朋友
準備好了嗎?
哈囉
我是任容萱
恭喜初日醫學 YouTube 頻道
突破一百萬訂閱
哈囉大家好
我是路嘉怡
在這邊要恭喜
宋醫師初日醫學的頻道
訂閱破百萬
恭喜初日破百萬訂閱啦
恭喜初日醫學也要破百萬了
初日診所的 YouTube 頻道
終於突破百萬訂閱
真的是太厲害了
那我在這邊也要特別感謝初日診所
他給了我一個改變人生的機會
謝謝初日陪我度過艱難的減脂期
讓我們在減脂的路上
不孤單
謝謝初日醫學
謝謝你們
幫助我學會好好的善待自己
在跟初日的合作當中
我獲得了健康
然後還有全新的人生觀
這點非常的開心
希望更多人也可以因此受惠
你也值得一個改變人生的機會
那麼在未來呢
也拜託你們一定要繼續
陪伴守護我們
全方位的身心靈健康
祝頻道長紅
我愛初日
坐等你們的下一集影片囉
今天我們一起走到了100萬
接下來的路
初日醫學會持續用知識陪著你
希望你能更靠近那個
更自在更健康的自己
最後跟大家說
謝謝你
讓我們的努力有了意義
我們下支影片再見囉